the glow is a soup of super heated irons
howling around the hollow doughnut shape
reactor
then the moment of fusion happens and
ends just seconds later
if it looks a bit like science fiction
that's because until recently it was
no one has captured this much energy for
this long from fusion this is a quest it
matters so much to find a sustainable
form of energy for for the planet and
over the last few years we've had a
bunch of hurdles challenges that we've
had to overcome
that the results today show that we can
do that and we can overcome all those
hurdles those challenges that's why it's
so important to us fusion's potential is
huge it's the process that powers our
sun its fuel is in limitless supply and
unlike nuclear fission that runs
conventional nuclear plants there's no
long-lived waste
with nuclear fission atoms of
radioactive metals split releasing
energy in the form of heat in nuclear
fusion two different forms of hydrogen
fuse together making helium
but fusion releases four times more
energy than nuclear fission
this is the engineering model of the
inside of the jet machine the
temperature needed to make fusion happen
is 10 times hotter than the sun 150
million degrees so when this thing is
running it's the hottest thing in the
solar system so nuclear fusion does have
the potential to transform civilization
but the practical realities of making it
happen here on earth are enormous
here at jet for example they must use
more energy to achieve fusion than they
get from it
but it's proven the science and is
developing the tools like precision
robotic handling needed for the next
fusion machine nearing completion in the
south of france
the eta machine say fusion scientists is
the final step before a commercial
reactor
only commitment stands in the way
we have shown them
that this can work from an engineering
point of view from a physics point of
view the challenge is there
they cannot hide
but we've shown them that this is
possible now take it up and take it
seriously
the truth remains fusion power won't be
with us for decades too late for the
current climate crisis but given a
fusion reactor makes four million times
more energy per gram of fuel than coal
oil or gas its potential to create a
brighter future is just too great to
ignore
tom clark sky news oxfordshire